.
>>> WELCOME TO "THE LEAD."
I'M JAKE TAPPER.
IT COULD BE THE FIRST IN 30
YEARS, A FREIGHT RAIL STRIKE
LOOMING CLOSER COULD BEGIN AS
SOON AS FRIDAY MORNING.
ABOUT 60,000 WORKERS ARE SET TO
WALK OFF THE JOB IF UNIONS AND
MANAGEMENT FAIL TO COME TO AN
AGREEMENT IN THE NEXT DAY AND A
HALF.
THE CONSEQUENCES FROM THIS COULD
BE, FRANKLY, ECONOMICALLY
DEVASTATING.
GAS PRICES WHICH HAVE BEEN
DRASTICALLY FALLING FROM THEIR
SUMMER PEAK COULD ONCE AGAIN
SKYROCKET IF TRAINS CARRYING
FUEL STOP MOVING.
HARVESTED CROPS COULD BE
PREVENTED FROM REACHING FOOD
FACTORIES, STOPPING STAPLES FROM
REACHING GROCERY STORES.
AMTRAK IS ALREADY CANCELING
ALMOST ALL OF ITS LONG-DISTANCE
PASSENGER TRAINS STARTING
TOMORROW AS MOST OF THEIR ROUTES
RUN ON FREIGHT TRACKS,
DISRUPTING TRAVEL ACROSS THE
UNITED STATES.
EVEN YOUR HOLIDAY SHOPPING COULD
BE AT RISK.
THE NATIONAL RETAIL FEDERATION
SAYING THAT THE RAIL STRIKE
COULD PREVENT STORES FROM
STOCKING UP ON GOODS AHEAD OF
THE HOLIDAY RUSH.
WE'RE GOING TO START OUR
COVERAGE TODAY WITH MORE ON THE
DOWN TO THE WIRE NEGOTIATIONS
BETWEEN THE UNIONS AND RAIL
MANAGEMENT COMPANIES, AND THE
ONE DETAIL THAT BOTH SIDES
CANNOT SEEM TO AGREE UPON.
>> Reporter: IT IS THE LATEST
EFFORT TO PUT THE BRAKES ON A
POSSIBLE RAIL WORKERS STRIKE
THAT COULD DEAL A MAJOR BLOW TO
THE ECONOMY.
WEDNESDAY BOSSES REPRESENTING
UNIONS AND RAILROADS MET WITH
THE LABOR SECRETARY IN A
LAST-DITCH EFFORT TO REACH A
DEAL BY MIDNIGHT THURSDAY.
THAT'S WHEN 60,000 WORKERS COULD
WALK OFF THE JOB AND N
SOLIDARITY WITH -- IN SOLIDARITY
WITH TRAIN ENGINEERS FIGHTING
FOR SICK TIME.
A STRIKE WOULD MEAN FREIGHT RAIL
WOULD GRIND TO A HALT IMPACTING
EVERYTHING FROM PARTS FOR CARS
TOFURT LISER FOR FARMING -- TO
FERTILIZER FOR FARMING.
>> TRANSPORTATION'S A BIG PART
OF THE COST TO THE CONSUMER.
AND I DON'T BELIEVE THERE'S ONE
PERSON IN THE COUNTRY THAT IT
WON'T EFFECT.
>> Reporter: STARTING THURSDAY
SOME RAILROADS WILL STOP
ACCEPTING SHIPMENTS OF GRAIN
CRITICAL TO FEED LIVESTOCK AND
POTENTIALLY FURTHER DRIVING UP
COSTS AT SUPERMARKETS.
RAIL PASSENGERS WILL BE
IMPACTED, TOO.
AMTRAK IS CANCELING ALL OF ITS
LONG DISTANCE ROUTES OUTSIDE OF
THE NORTHEAST CORRIDOR.
IN CHICAGO, NINE OF 11 COMMUTER
LINES WILL STOP WHEN A STRIKE
BEGINS.
>> I'VE BEEN COMMUTING FROM THE
SUBURBS TO CHICAGO NOW FOR OVER
30 YEARS.
I COULD NEVER REMEMBER THIS
HAPPENING.
COULD TAKE TWO HOURS IF I'M
DRIVING.
ON TRAIN IT'S 40 MINUTES.
>> Reporter: WITH MIDTERM
ELECTIONS ON THE HORIZON THE
PRESSURE IS ON THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TO REACH A
RESOLUTION.
THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF HAS CALLED
UNIONS AND EMPLOYERS, PUSHING
THEM TO RESOLVE THEIR
DIFFERENCES.
IF A FREIGHT RAIL SHUTDOWN DOES
HAPPEN, TRUCKING COMPANIES SAY
THEY CANNOT PICK UP THE SLACK.
>> IT STARTS WITH A VERY SMALL
IMPACT, BUT IT GROWS
GEOMETRICALLY.
>> Reporter: THE IMPACTS HERE
FAR AND WIDE, JAKE.
ONE MORE IMPACT -- THAT WATER
TREATMENT FACILITIES ARE WARNING
THEY MIGHT NOT BE ABLE TO GET
CHLORINE, CRITICAL TO CLEANING
WATER.
IT IS OFTEN SENT BY RAIL.
THE INTERESTING BYPRODUCT HERE,
JAKE, THERE COULD BE BOIL-WATER
ADVISORIES NATIONWIDE IF THERE
IS A FREIGHT RAIL SHUTDOWN.
JAKE?
>> ALL RIGHT.
THANKS SO MUCH.
AS PETE NOTED, RAILROAD AND
UNION OFFICIALS WERE SUMMONED TO
WASHINGTON, D.C., TODAY TO MEET
WITH THE SECRETARY OF LABOR,
MARTY WALSH.
THIS COMES AS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS WORKING
OVERTIME TO PREVENT A STRIKE.
LET'S BRING IN CNN'S MJ LEE WHO
COVERS THE WHITE HOUSE FOR US.
THIS MEETING STILL ONGOING AFTER
SEVERAL HOURS OF NEGOTIATIONS.
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT WHERE
THINGS STAND RIGHT NOW?
>> Reporter: YEAH, JAKE, WHILE
PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS BEEN
SPENDING THE DAY HERE AT THE
DETROIT AUTO SHOW, WE KNOW THAT
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS BEEN VERY
CLOSELY MONITORING THESE ONGOING
TALKS.
AND THESE TALKS DO APPEAR TO
STILL BE ONGOING.
WE KNOW THAT UNION AND RAILROAD
OFFICIALS HAVE BEEN MEETING WITH
MARTY WALSH, THE LABOR
SECRETARY.
AND THAT MEETING HAS BEEN
ONGOING FOR HOURS.
IN THE LAST HOUR OR SO, A WHITE
HOUSE OFFICIAL GAVE ME AN UPDATE
THAT THOSE TALKS ARE STILL
HAPPENING IN GOOD FAITH.
NOW THE PRESIDENT HIMSELF IN
RECENT DAYS HAS ALSO GOTTEN
INVOLVED DIRECTLY, PICKING UP
THE PHONE AND CALLING SOME PARTY
TO TRY GET THEM PAST THIS
IMPASSE.
AND THE GOAL, OF COURSE IS TO
AVERT A STRIKE.
WHITE HOUSE OFFICIALS KNOW VERY
WELL HOW ECONOMICALLY DAMAGING
ALL OF THIS COULD BE.
BUT THAT HAVING BEEN SAID, WE
ARE TOLD BY A WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIAL THAT THEY ARE STILL
WORKING ON CONTINGENCY PLANS,
INCLUDING FIGURING OUT OTHER
METHOD OF POTENTIAL
TRANSPORTATION TO GET SOME OF
THESE GOODS MOVING, AND ALSO TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT AND ISOLATE
WHAT KINDS OF COMMODITIES WOULD
BE MOST SEVERELY HIT.
THEY ARE PLANNING FOR ALL
POSSIBILITIES BUT HOPING THAT
SOMETHING WILL COME TO A DEAL.
>> I DON'T NEED TO TELL YOU
ABOUT THIS, BUT THE RAILROADS
WORK UNDER A UNIQUE LABOR LAW
THAT ALLOWS THE TO OF THE TO
INTERVENE TO PREVENT A STRIKE.
THEY CAN IMPOSE TEMPORARY
REGULATIONS WHILE CONTINUING
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE UNIONS.
ARE YOU HEARING ANY WORD THAT
ANYONE IN THE GOVERNMENT IS
CONSIDERING THIS?
>> Reporter: YEAH, YOU KNOW, THE
SHORT ANSWER FOR NOW SEEMS TO BE
THAT CONGRESS IS NOT VERY
INTERESTED IN INTERVENING.
JUST TAKE A NOTE OF THE FACT
THAT YESTERDAY SENATOR DICK
DURBIN TOLD OUR COLLEAGUE ON
CAPITOL HILL, HE SAID, "I DON'T
THINK IT'S LIKELY THAT WE WILL
INTERVENE."
WHAT HE BASICALLY SAID IS HE
THINKS IT'S UP TO THE DIFFERENT
PARTIES TO GET TO THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE AND FIGURE OUT
A DEAL ON THEIR OWN.
AND ALSO HOUSE SPEAKER NANCY
PELOSI JUST TODAY TELLING
REPORTERS, "I'D RATHER SEE THE
NEGOTIATIONS PREVAIL SO THAT
CONGRESS DOESN'T HAVE TO ACT."
SO ALL INDICATIONS RIGHT NOW AT
LEAST FOR THE TIME BEING IS THAT
THERE'S LITTLE APPETITE ON
CAPITOL HILL FOR THEM TO
ACTUALLY HAVE TO INTERVENE.
AGAIN, THESE EVENTS ARE SO
FLUID, THESE TALKS ARE STILL
ONGOING.
WE DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN.
BUT JUST IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE
AGAIN THERE'S LITTLE APPETITE ON
CAPITOL HILL RIGHT NOW FOR
LAWMAKERS TO GET INVOLVED AND
INTERVENE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THE U.S. RAIL STRIKE COULD COST
THE COUNTRY TENS OF MILLIONS OF
DOLLARS EVERY DAY.
WHAT IS THAT GOING TO MEAN FOR
THE U.S. ECONOMY?
WE HAVE MORE FROM RAHEL SOLOMON.
WHAT DID HE HAVE TO SAY?
>> MARK ZANDY FROM MOODY'S TOLD
ME IN THE HOUR THAT THIS WOULD
MASSIVELY AFFECT THINGS FROM THE
FED.
THINK ABOUT WHERE WE'RE COMING
FROM.
WE HAD THE MASSIVE SUPPLY SHOCK
FROM THE PANDEMIC WHICH WE ARE
TRYING TO GET OUT FROM, WE HAVE
RUSSIA'S INVASION OF UKRAINE
WHICH HAS STILL HAMPERED SUPPLY
CHAINS.
AND THIS WOULD BE THE THIRD MAY
HAVE SHOCK.
THIS WOULD MAKE IT HARDER.
IN TERMS OF CONSUMERS IT WOULD
MEAN SHORTAGES OF PRODUCTS, NOT
IN THE NEAR TERM BUT AS THE
WEEKS ON, IN THE LONG TERM, IT
WOULD MEAN HIGHER INFLATION AS
SUPPLY IS OUTSTRIPPED BY DEMAND.
HE PUT IT THIS WAY, LOOK, IF
THIS GOES ON FOR TWO TO THREE
WEEKS OR CERTAINLY LONGER IT
BECOMES A MACROECONOMIC ISSUE.
THEN I THINK IT STARTS AFFECTING
ACTIVITY AND MANUFACTURING AND
THE AGRICULTURE SECTOR AND
CONSTRUCTION, TRANSPORTATION,
DISTRIBUTION MORE BROADLY.
IT JUST BECOMES A REAL MESS.
AND THAT MESS AND THAT POTENTIAL
IMPACT IS WHY YOU'RE HEARING
FROM SO MANY STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT
THE POTENTIAL IMPACT OF THIS.
IT COULD HAVE AN IMPACT TO US
CONSUMERS IN TERMS OF SHORTAGES
OF GOODS AT GROCERY STORES.
THINK ABOUT ALSO THE AUTOMOTIVE
INDUSTRY.
IT IMPACTS NOT JUST THE FINISHED
PRODUCTS, THE CARS, BUT THEIR
SUPPLIES, THEIR GOODS, THEIR
PARTS, WHICH THEY'VE ALREADY
BEEN DEALING WITH THE SUPPLY
CHAIN ISSUE.
PART OF THE REASON CARS ARE SO